[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
ELIZABETH CRONISE
MCLAUGHLIN: Hi.
So it's a privilege to be here.
Thank you all for taking
your time today out
of your busy day to hear
me talk about warrior
women in leadership.
Excuse me.
And I'm getting over a little
bit of a cold so if I cough,
I hope you understand.
I'm armed and dangerous
with water up here.
So this is a topic that's
near and dear to my heart.
I've been doing
women's leadership
work for really my whole life.
But in my corporate
environment, our Gaia Project
for Women's Leadership
arm really goes
into corporations like Google
and plenty of other places,
and helps women
leaders to achieve.
One of the things that's really
key to where we find ourselves
right now, though, at
this moment in history,
is that, as you all
know, we're in the midst
of a massive cultural shift.
Really a tectonic shift
in women's leadership.
And that means certain
things right now
for what women leaders
are doing and the way
in which we're
operating that is very
different from the messages
that we've had before.
And the ways in which leadership
has functioned before as well,
because we're having more
influence than we've ever
had before on the leadership
of companies, institutions,
governments-- not withstanding
where we find ourselves
at the moment.
And also that we are
in a position where
our skills as women leaders are
influencing how corporations
function generally.
So we're going to talk
through today warrior
women in leadership as
it stands right now,
and give you guys some really
practical tools to walk away
from in terms of
what this means,
and what it means for
leadership and what it means
for professional development,
and also what it means
for our culture and our world.
One of the things that
I want to just start
with is, what is a warrior
woman in leadership?
What does that look
like right now?
So when I talk about warrior
women, what I'm talking about
is how we have armed
ourselves for change
in this corporate and
cultural environment
that we're in right now.
Warrior women in
leadership to me
is about an activist model
of women's leadership.
And we're going to
talk through what
that looks like in the
context of your everyday.
But we've seen more and
more women really rising
to create change, especially
in the last 12 months,
I think for obvious reasons.
And we're also obviously,
as I mentioned,
seeing major cultural
shifts right now.
So one of the things
that is important
when we talk about warrior
women in leadership
is the historic
backward-looking viewpoint
of where we find ourselves.
So traditional masculine
models of leadership
generally only measure
two metrics that matter.
The time that we invest
and how much money we make,
whether that's the money we
make for ourselves or the money
that we make for others.
And those models are
really difficult for women
to rise within for a
variety of reasons.
Because many of us
choose to have children,
because many of us historically
also do so much more
work at home than we
do out in the world.
And the metrics that we
measure our success by also
are different, because
generally speaking, we're
more concerned with the
quality of our lives--
and this is a broad
overgeneralization--
but we're more concerned the
quality of our lives in total.
And this is why we
don't often hear
men talking about work/life
balance in the same way
that we do women--
than men tend to be.
And so one of the things that
is important to think about here
is, who do we have as
role models for warrior
women in leadership look like?
Or what women leaders
look like generally.
And as I talked
through warrior women
as a concept in the
first stages of getting
ready for this talk,
one of the things
that really struck me is that
going back in our history,
women in general have
lost a lot of our history.
It's been erased
and there's a lot
that's been written
about this generally.
I really encourage
you to look at it
because you'll be amazed by what
has been wiped from the history
books.
But we have had stories
going all the way back
to the Odyssey of how
men go through journeys
that make them leaders.
The hero's journey is
a trope that we're all
deeply familiar with.
And one of the things
that we haven't had
historically is the
journey of a heroine.
What does the journey
of a woman look
like when we are progressing
toward our highest leadership?
And so one of the things that
I want to start with today
is a discussion of what
the heroine's journey might
look like in the
context of the history
that we know of from
the hero's journey.
So the heroine's journey is
one that, as an initial matter,
I want to say this about.
It's not like we go
through this journey once.
One of the things that the
studies show about the way
that women learn, for instance,
is that we learn cyclically,
generally, much more than we
learn in a linear fashion.
And so you may have noticed
that my corporate logo,
for instance, is a spiral.
There's a reason for that.
It's because the
journey that we are
on as women leaders continues
to cycle around over and over
again.
So what I'm going to
share with you today
in the context of this
journey is something
that I want to make very clear.
You're not just going
to go through once.
Some heroine's journeys are
harder than others, right?
We're in a particular
one as a culture
right now for women leaders
that is quite brutal,
I think we can all agree.
And yet at the same time,
we cycle back continuously
to learn over and over
again the things that we
need to learn on our path.
So as you think through
this for yourself
in the context of what this
might mean for your life,
as you think through
what it might
mean for you in the
context of the women
you know and the
women you work with,
please remember that
it's not like this
is all just an
over and done game.
I wish it was It would probably
be a lot easier on all of us.
So where we start
the warrior woman
journey, the heroine's
journey, is first
in the place of illusion.
And when we think about
women's leadership,
this is the place where
we talk about conformity.
So it's the idea that if
we dress a certain way,
if we lean in enough.
And don't get me wrong,
I'm a fan of Sheryl,
but I have to say I have very
strong opinions about what
"Lean In" has done
for women leaders,
and they're not all very good.
If we show up in the right
way as assertive but not
too assertive, as opinionated
but not too opinionated.
If we smile enough, if we
are people-pleasing enough,
we will get along just fine
in these traditional masculine
leadership environments.
That is the place of illusion.
And I'm going to talk
through a little bit more
what this looks like
in greater detail,
but this is where we
started our journey.
With the belief that
if we cope, if we
have coping skills
that work for us,
then everything will be fine.
Unfortunately, I
think many of us
can recognize that that's
generally not the way it works.
And so the next stage
on the heroine's journey
is the stage of betrayal.
And this is the place
where you recognize
that your coping
mechanisms have failed you.
That you can still do it
all, and do it all in the way
that we've been told you have
to do it to succeed as a woman,
and still not have it happen.
And part of that is
systemic, and part of that
is because we've been
taught that this is
the only way that we can do it.
Don't worry, we're going
deeper into all of this.
The next stage of
the heroine's journey
is the one of awakening.
And this is really
the place of choice.
You have a choice
about whether or not
you're going to just
continue coping,
or you have a choice
about whether or not
you're going to rise and fight.
And I don't necessarily mean
this in the Wonder Woman way,
but that's kind of a nice
little image to get in your head
if you would care to.
The awakening is the
moment of recognizing
that where we have been
can no longer continue
and where we are going has
to be something different,
and we are the
agent of that change
either individually
or collectively.
Then comes the descent.
And this is the really
kind of not nice place
in the heroine's journey.
This is the place where we
start to recognize the cost.
And we recognize
the cost of what
we have paid to get
where we are currently,
we recognize the cost
of continuing to fight,
we recognize that
nothing is ever
going to quite be the same
from where we find ourselves.
And by the way, this all may
sound very culturally familiar
in terms of where we find
ourselves right now as well.
And it is the place where
we choose our tools.
And before we leave
today, I'm going
to talk through what some of
these tools a.k.a. weapons
might look like in the context
of warrior women in leadership.
But it is a place
where we determine
what it is that we need
to succeed in a new model.
The descent.
The pit at the bottom
of the heroine's journey
is the hurricane.
This is the place where we
experience the maelstrom
of transformation.
Some of you who
follow me on Facebook
know that I have this thing that
I talk about in terms of where
we are culturally
right now, which is
the cauldron of transformation.
The way it feels like everything
is on fire, we're boiling,
so much is changing in our
culture and in our world right
now, and in our nation.
And it's swirling all around us.
The dangerous point
of the hurricane
is that sometimes there
are points of relief.
It's like the eye of the storm
and we're like, oh, maybe
it's not quite so bad.
Maybe I can let my guard down.
Maybe I don't have
to fight so hard.
And then lo and
behold, the next thing
you know, the next
day you're back in it
and we're off to
the races again.
So the hurricane is
really the bottom,
and it's where we need the
most tools that we can possibly
prepare ourselves for.
The next stage is loss.
And this is really the
place where we come face
to face with the
grief of what we
have to sacrifice
in order to move on
to a new way of doing things.
This is a place, by the
way, that many of us
find ourselves in right now.
As I mentioned, I host
this daily broadcast
on Facebook called
Resistance Live,
and just last night I
had to post something
about I know everybody
feels like they're
in a pit of despair
and in the pit of grief
based on what has happened
in the last couple of days
in our nation.
Please recognize
the grief is real,
and also recognize that
this place that we're in
is not going to last forever.
Lost on the heroine's
journey necessarily
leads to intervention.
Now some of you who may know
the historic heroes journeys
may recognize this is
the point where like
the gods send in the tools.
Right?
You know, Zeus kind of throws
down the lightning bolts
and all of a sudden
everything gets better.
In our case, intervention
is actually really
about connection.
Because it's about
taking on our own agency
and connecting with other
women to move forward.
And again, we're going
to talk through this
in a bit more depth.
But intervention is
the moment of change.
It's a moment where we
adopt our own agency
and step forward to
make the world more
of what we want as women.
And then rebirth.
That's the place where we
really build the future
and continue to move
forward toward the world
that we want to live in.
And then we return to
our home territory,
back to the top of the cycle.
And again remember we're
spiraling through all of this
all the time.
So rebirth and return
is really about return
to a place of stasis,
not return to the place
that we were before.
And so the journey
of the warrior woman
is one that, and
this is going to be
a theme in what we discuss next,
is a place of constant growth.
It's not like the
change ever stops.
It may ease up
from time to time,
but the growth is continuous.
So where does this
take us in the context
of women in leadership?
And particularly in corporate,
but also in government,
and politics, and
nonprofit, in our lives,
and how we move forward.
So the place we start
on this is at the place
of illusion, which is that
what we were promised is a lie.
And this one is a
particularly tough one,
I think, for a lot
of us to swallow,
because for many of us who
came up as women leaders, what
we were told was, again, you
do all these things right
and it's going to be just fine.
Right?
All you have to
do is x, y, and z,
and every time that you
don't quite make it,
there's just one more little
thing that you need to do.
You add to that
the myth that women
have been indoctrinated
with, which is the idea
that we can have it all.
Right?
That there is an
all to even have.
And that if we do all the right
things in terms of our home
life and our work
life, and we cope
and we hire the right
help when we need it,
or we seek out other resources
just to make it all work,
that somehow we're going to
hit some perfect balance,
it's going to allow us to feel
like we've hit some arbitrary
measure of success.
This whole thing is a lie.
And the key point
about this illusion
that I want to just
make at the moment
is that we're starting to see
all of this disintegrate right
now in our culture.
Right?
The idea that, again--
me too maps very
strongly onto what
I'm going to talk about
today-- but the idea
that we have to just put
up with a certain degree
of discrimination.
A little bit of harassment here.
We're just not going
to talk about it.
This is just part of what
you have to put up with
in order to achieve on the job.
All of that, lie.
Illusion.
So where does this
take us to now?
We get to the point of
betrayal next in the journey.
And what I want
to say about this
is that women's leadership
advocacy has done a lot.
Right?
I don't want to
discount that there
are some very powerful voices
out there in the leadership
methodology that I work
in in my industry who
have done an awful lot
to help women succeed.
But what we have failed
to do is teach women
how to become their
own best advocates.
To teach women how
to work together
as change agents in leadership.
And so to me, lifelong
feminist right
here, I just want to say that.
Very big believer
in the principles
of equality and equity that
many of us are working toward.
We have not gone far enough in
the context of helping women
to claim their own authority.
It feels often as
though what we're doing
is pleading for change
rather than stepping forward
and effecting change ourselves.
And so the standpoint
of betrayal
is the point where we recognize
that the coping skills that we
had before that we
have been taught,
sometimes taught by one another,
are not enough to get us
where we want to go.
So the next place that
we come to is awakening.
And this is the principle of
why we need warrior women.
So one of the things that
I want to emphasize here
when I talk about this
is that the impact
of powerful, embodied
activist women
leaders on corporate
cultures and the world
is potentially dramatic.
Because one of the things
that we have to recognize
is that we have different
ways of leading than what
we have seen traditionally.
And the studies bear
this out, right?
We are more collaborative,
we are more communicative.
Corporations that
have more women
on their boards of directors
are investigated less,
they're more productive,
they're more profitable,
they generate more revenue,
generally speaking,
compared to their peers.
And all of this has
to do with the fact
that women, as leaders, connect.
So warrior women in
every environment
can make a difference,
assuming that we
are empowered to step
forward and create change.
And so the point of awakening
is the point that each one of us
decides that we are going
to step forward and claim
our ability to advocate for
different models of leadership.
And I want to
encourage all of you,
no matter where you find
yourselves in your career
points at this point,
to think about what's
the choice that you have
in front of you right now
to make more of a
difference in your lives,
in your working environments,
in your culture, in your world.
What's the choice that you
are faced with right now
that may lead you to become
more of a voice for the change
that you want to
see in the world?
Because it benefits everything.
It impacts everything
that we do right now.
So this brings me to
a point of critique.
Here we are in the descent.
And one of the
things that you all
may remember from
back in 2016 is
that when we had Hillary
Clinton running for president,
we saw a lot of
these what I like
to refer to as lady power
movements or commodity
feminism.
Right?
All of these kind
of like powder pink
websites for
women's empowerment,
and if you just
wear the right suit
you put on the
right pair of heels,
everything's going to be OK.
And I will admit
that in my industry,
I worked for some of these.
What a lot of
people don't know is
that I actually used to
collaborate with Ivanka Trump
many moons ago.
But that is a prime example
of commodity feminism.
It's selling a solution that
is not internal to yourself.
And so part of the
messaging here in terms
of how do we build stronger
women's leadership,
it has to be about
self origination.
One of the things that I
talk about all the time
in corporate environments where
I train and teach women leaders
is the idea that when we
change what's on the inside,
we inevitably change
what's on the outside.
And so it's not like
there is some easy,
one size fits all solution
that shifts us toward equity.
We have to be
empowered internally
to make the shifts that are
necessary to step forward
to effect change.
So combining feminism
is the descent.
And by the way, this
is also the point where
we start to recognize the cost.
Right?
Where we start to look
inside ourselves and see,
I've been guilted,
I have been shamed
into not being good enough.
I have been told that
my voice is meaningless.
What does that mean in terms
of what are the tools that I'm
going to pick up next?
How can I communicate
more effectively?
How do I need to
refine the way that I
operate in every environment
so that I'm using my voice?
And so one of the
things that we talk
about when we talk about
tools, and I talk about this
in just a couple minutes
a little bit more,
is the idea that we do need
to adopt new weapons as women
in leadership.
So that may look like things
like nonviolent communication.
And for those of
you who don't know,
nonviolent
communication strategies
were developed by Marshall
Rosenberg in the 1970s,
and there are means by which
you can effectively communicate
your needs and
wants so that they
are heard from the perspective
of the person on the other side
of the table from
you with compassion.
This is a skill set, by the way,
that I think everybody needs
in every corporate environment.
It is very much about what I
experience, what I witness,
what I value, and
then requesting buy in
in a collaborative way.
That skill set is one that
for women in leadership
is absolutely
critical because we
need to be able to learn
to advocate in ways that
are different from pounding the
table to demand what we want.
Very much traditional
masculine leadership model.
Whereas our collaborative
means of asking for change
and propelling forward
in communication
can actually shift things
and help others to see
the value of what we're after.
So that's one tool.
But I will also just add that in
a lot of corporate environments
these days, there's a
lot of toxicity underway
and some of the tools that we
need to think about empowering
ourselves with are tools
that 5, 10 years ago,
I couldn't teach in
corporate environments.
Things like, how do you protect
your energy so that when
you're under attack--
which we're about to
get to in a minute,
we're getting into
the hurricane--
you know that you're not
taking on and internalizing
the negative messaging
you're getting?
How can you step forward and
feel empowered in your body
and in your
presentation so that you
are making an impact that
shows others that you
are not to be messed with.
All of these skill
sets and tools
are new ones that
we need to learn.
And so one of the things
that I do recommend
for women leaders who are in
the ground, on the battlefield
everyday with this,
is that you think
through how the experience that
you have as a warrior woman
is affecting you.
Are you internalizing
negative messaging?
Are you having a
hard time with how
you can advocate and
succeed and keep going?
You may need to refine
your skill set in this way.
And these are the baseline,
on the ground skills
that I teach everyday in
corporate environments.
But it is an important
point of recognition
that we need new
tools for new times.
So now we get to the hurricane.
And this is how warrior
women are punished.
So one of the things
that I like to be
very blunt about in the
warrior women journey
that I'm talking about today is
nobody is saying this is easy.
Right?
No one is saying
that like, woo, we're
all going to step forward in
life, kick some ass, and win,
it's all just going to
get better overnight.
Warrior women are
punished relentlessly.
All we have to do is look
at the 2016 election.
It's about how you talk,
the sound of your voice,
how you laugh, what
you wear, your hair,
your makeup, your body,
whether or not you're
meeting certain
codes that convey
certain bits of information
that make you qualified or not.
And I will also
just add that as we
work to transform
our culture and we
work to transform our
society, privilege
is a hard thing to let go of.
Right?
We see the experience
right now of old ways
of doing things, old
models of leadership,
old means of operation clinging
on by their fingernails
to avoid any change
in the world.
And one of the things that
means is that crazy attacks
will come out of nowhere.
Pizza parlors in Washington
DC come to mind, for instance.
The level at which we
have to be prepared
to go to battle for the
world that we want to build
is significant.
And as well, it's critical
in this environment
that we work together
to hold one another up.
So one of the things
that I talk about when
we talk about the importance of
collaboration as a way through
and connection as
a way through is
the issue of why we're
better off together.
So one of the things that I want
to point out here, by the way,
is that traditional male
models of leadership
encourage women to
compete with one another.
That's because we've been
told that there's only room
for so many of us at the top.
That, by the way, is
part of the big lie.
And one of the
things that it means
is that when we are
competing with one another,
when we are tearing
one another down,
when we are not helping
to lift other women up
in the corporate
environment or elsewhere,
we are not focused on
how we can work together
to actually effect change.
It's a really convenient
self-reinforcing mechanism
of patriarchy that women like
to tear each other down and beat
each other up.
And so one of the things
that I really encourage here
is that we think about
how we can instead
adopt a model-- this is
a very serious thought
leadership pivot, but instead
adopt a model that says when
one of us wins, we all rise.
This is a very hard thing for
women to internalize, honestly,
because we've been raised in a
culture that says that's just
not the way it works.
But my standpoint on
this is the following.
When we recognize how much
damage we've done to one
another-- and this is really
why we're sitting in the place
of lose when we
talk about this--
how much harm we've
done to one another
by not adopting a thought
process that says,
let me see how I can
help my sister up.
We recognize all
the time that's been
lost that would have
effected change before now,
and it also propels us to make
change more in the future.
So the image I like
to work with on this
is the idea of an ever-ascending
pillar of humanity.
Women, if you would like to
think about it in that way,
it can just be women, but
I honestly think about it
as gender neutral.
And the idea of it is that
we leave no one behind
in hopelessness.
We leave no one behind
without opportunity.
And so when one of our sisters
is falling off the pillar,
you are the person
who leans down
with your hand to grab
her and pull her back up.
This as an image, as a
metaphor functions so well
in the idea of how we can effect
change in the environments
that we are in.
Because when we see someone
struggling, another woman
struggling, when we see
another woman working
so hard to succeed, what can
we do to help lift her up?
Rather than saying,
oh, she sucks,
let me just let her fail
over there on her own.
The more that we can consider
the collaborative nature of how
we can work together and abandon
this idea of the zero sum
game--
by the way, the quote I
always refer to on this front
is Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
She was asked one time
how many women needed
to be on the Supreme Court to
make her happy and she said,
nine.
And the reporter was
horrified by that story.
And she said, what?
You know, for centuries it was
nine men on the Supreme Court.
What's wrong with the idea of
all women on the Supreme Court
all put together?
And it's such a shocking
idea to us, right?
Because we've been
convinced that there's just
this tiny little slot
that we have to fit into.
So the pivot of abandoning
the zero sum game,
and then moving toward a place
of collective and collaborative
advocacy as women makes
a huge difference in what
we're able to accomplish.
And so that takes us to
several points of intervention
here, one of which is how to
be a warrior woman at work.
And we're going to talk through
a couple of different ways
in which we can be warrior women
here to really effect change.
And I'll just say
to all the guys
in the room I want to
just really appreciate
your listening to all of this
too because the skill sets
are honestly gender neutral.
But from the perspective
of what warrior women need
to do in the workplace, we're
at a really interesting turning
point right now.
So to me, this is
about a refusal
to accept the status quo.
So if you are in a
working environment
where you've seen instances
of unconscious bias
and you have not
shouted it out, this
is now where it needs to start.
If you are aware
in your workplace
that somebody has been
discriminated against
or harassed, silence
is no longer an option.
We are really in
a place right now
from the standpoint of advocacy
where we're at zero tolerance.
And again, me too is a
prime example of this
because you see all the
seething frustration
underneath the surface of what
women and others, it's not just
women, but women in
predominant numbers
have experience that
has caused such rage.
Such as rage at all the
dreams that have been lost,
all the opportunities that
have been taken from us,
the experiences that have
been mapped onto our bodies.
And from the perspective of
how we shift this, some of it
has to be about
speaking the unspoken.
Right?
For the first time
ever, saying the things
that we have been told we
are not allowed to say.
Telling stories that we've
been told over and over again
that we are not allowed to tell.
And simply the use of
our voices in that way
in work environments changes
the corporate culture.
And I'll tell you, I do work
inside investment banks,
huge financial institutions,
publicly traded companies
all the time.
The ability of women when they
are empowered to actually speak
the truth of their experiences
in those environments
can change those
cultures overnight.
Because all of a sudden
it's not like there
are unspoken things,
hidden stories that
are oppressing certain
qualities and preventing women
fundamentally from living
out their true gifts.
Right?
Because this is really
what it's all about for me.
It's about talent and
it's about why we're here.
It's about talent and purpose.
And so one of the other things
that's really important to me
when I talk about warrior
women in leadership at work
is that we think
through why we're here.
What's the purpose?
Right?
And if we look
back at the metrics
I started with of traditional
masculine models of leadership
only valuing money and
time, what warrior women
and women in general in
leadership bring to the table
is an idea that we are all here
with certain gifts that can be
contributed to the collective.
And the metric that I talk about
when I go in even in gender
neutral environments to
teach about leadership
is the idea that we
shift from that metric
toward a metric of growth.
Continuous growth.
Continuous growth of service.
And part of that requires
each and every one of us
to be able to recognize
the gifts and the purpose
for why we're here,
fundamentally.
So to me, one of the things that
has to happen in order for us
to be able to fully embody our
gifts, to live on our purpose,
to serve out in the way
that we need to serve
is that those stories are taken
away so that the true totality
of our voices can be heard.
And so part of this aspect
of stepping completely
into our leadership
was warrior women
has to be about that
use of voice that
then allows us to contribute
our gifts in different ways.
Does that make
sense to everybody?
I hope so.
And you know, one
of the things that I
want to say about this
is well just while we're
on the topic of purpose is that
if we are measuring success
by consistent
standards of growth,
are we growing ourselves?
Are we growing our teams?
And this is not like the
bottom line revenue growth
we're talking about, right?
It's about the
growth of the impact
that you want to
make in the world.
If we are focused
on that, then we
are asking different questions
about what success looks like.
And this is where we get to
have a true benefit for women
in leadership because if we are
modeling success on our growth,
on our collaboration, on
the difference that we make
in the world, then
inherently we care more
about things like the
quality of our lives.
We care more about
whether or not
we can create work
environments where
women can contribute even if
they've got children at home.
We work to create
cultural shifts that
allow for childcare to be
absolutely available to all
of us so that we have an
opportunity to contribute
at the totality of our gifts.
So the mental pivot
away from money and time
as the only metric towards
different models of success
is really key here.
And I hope that makes sense.
OK.
Just a little bit on
warrior womaning at home.
One of the things that I
just want to point out here
is that even in households
where women are primary earners,
we still do 2/3 of
the housework and we
do right now at this moment
in time 50 percent more
childcare than women
did in the 50s.
Believe it or not.
That's because models of
parenting have changed.
Pew Research, if you go
look at these numbers,
it's astonishing.
One of the things that
I want to make plain
when we talk about
cultural shifts
here is that everything that we
do, by the way, is political.
I mean, I think this
is kind of a given
if you've been in
a feminist movement
at all in any way,
shape, or form.
But the most intimate
conversations
that we have about our needs
and being supported inevitably
impact the way that
we are in the world.
And so one of the things
that is key here in the way
that I think about this
is that if we are not
able to ask for what we need
in our home environments,
it also therefore becomes
much more difficult for us
to ask for it in the world.
And so even at the tiny
baseline conversations
that we have with our
partners and our spouses
about like who's
doing the dishes.
Right?
Who's taking care of the kids?
Do we need help?
How can I get help?
I myself am a single mom
and I'm really big on
like, can we create
collaborative models
in our communities that
can help to support women
in different ways that maybe
have not been discussed
before that are outside
of our old school
historic model of women
doing women's work at home,
and men being out
working in the world?
We need to start getting
creative about the solutions
that we seek here.
Those proactive
conversations where
we draw a line in
the sand and say,
this isn't working
for me anymore,
let me think creatively about
how to make it different,
inevitably lead us
to places of being
able to have more
high-stakes conversations out
in the world at large.
And so we can't forget that.
Right?
And I also just want to
mention one other thing here.
I do not believe in
work/life balance.
I think again it's
like a total myth
that it could even be possible.
I think what is
possible, however,
is to have lives that are in
alignment with what we value.
And for each of us,
that's a unique metric.
Right?
What do I value most in my life?
How do I create a life
that gives me that?
And if we are not thinking
about that individually
for ourselves, we also can't
create solutions for it
in the collective.
So starting at the
baseline of, what
do I need most in my own home,
is a really important way
to lead to being able and
more courageous to have
higher-stakes conversations
in other places.
OK.
And lastly, the
point of intervention
of how to be a warrior
woman in the world.
So one of the things
about activist women's
leadership that to me is so
compelling at this moment
in time is that we are in
a place where we actually
have an opportunity and
make a massive difference.
Like the world is
cracking open right now.
And the opportunity for change
and to create a future that we
want to live in
is more compelling
now and more
possible now, I even
think, despite the dark days
that we seem to be living in,
than it's been for
quite some time.
I think we can all-- you
know, I'm 46 years old.
Those of us who are
60s and 70s babies
may have some vague recollection
of other historic turning
points in time where
opportunities like this
felt like they were possible.
This moment feels
particularly rich to me.
And I want to remind you all
of that in lots of mythologies,
the cremation ground, the
place where everything
is burned to ash, is actually
the most fertile place
for growth.
It's the place where you
can plant seeds and create
a future.
And so where we find ourselves
right now really has to be--
and I'm such a big advocate
for this in my daily existence
broadcasts-- a place where
we think about the future
that we want to live in to, and
we start living from that place
right now.
So that means, for
instance, that we don't--
how shall I put it?
We don't get down in the
gutter and fight dirty
if that's not the future
that we want to live in too.
And it means that if we make
choices about how we advocate.
We advocate from a place
of kindness and compassion
and acceptance.
It also means that we
are constantly working
toward the future that we want.
And so to me, part
of this as well
is about how do we stand
up and fight for the future
that we want in our
world, for our children,
in government, in the corporate
environments that we work in?
How, every day, can we step
into modeling the future
that we want to live in?
Not easy.
I to say this is not easy.
Managing our
emotions, especially
in times of turmoil and stress
and trauma in our nation,
is really, really hard.
And we have to
envision the world
that we want to live in to.
We're the people who are
going to lead the way on that,
by the way.
I mean, I hope that makes
sense that women who
step forward and
really own this moment
and take it through
the transformation.
You know, this is
like a birth process
we're in right now as a
culture and as a country.
We know how to
give birth, right?
And one of the
things that I think
is key there is that we
have to claim it, right?
No one swooping in to save
us on this front, right?
We have to be the
people who lead
the change at this moment in
time, to build that future,
because we can see it.
So it's a very
unique opportunity
where we are right
now, honestly.
And if I could kind of leave
everybody with a thought
here about what
we're leading into.
The question I get asked
more often than not is,
why or what is this vision
that you have of the future?
What is this going to look
like when we get there?
I did a speaking tour this fall
and that was the number one
question that I got
asked in every location
around the country was, what's
this vision of the future
that you have for women
and for all of us?
And so to me, the
point of this is
that we have an opportunity
now to create a world where
there is equity.
Where from the standpoint of
even just corporate hiring
and recruiting
policies, like where
are we going to recruit the next
generation of women leaders.
We can do all of
that differently.
Where we can do
things like pay equity
analyzes inside our companies
and see how people are getting
paid.
From that all the
way up to how do
we create a place where no one
is left behind in hopelessness.
A government that
represents all of us.
A world where everyone
has opportunity.
What does that look like?
To me, it looks
like a place where
we know that every
human life has value,
and where we step outside of the
arbitrary hierarchies of race,
and gender, and national
origin, and preference,
and everything
else, orientation,
and think through
the idea that--
the idea that there's an
arbitrary hierarchy of humans
is just that.
It's just a myth.
Right?
And so if we
approach the world we
want to live in from a place
of all of us having equality
and equity and value,
that means necessarily
that we can't have policies
that benefit some of us
don't benefit others.
Right?
That create artificial
differences between us
as humans.
And so to me, this is kind
of like the big kahuna.
We're in a big kahuna
moment right now.
And warrior women
will change the world
by being the people
who write the path.
Right?
I know a lot of this has been
a lot more esoteric and heady
than I anticipated
it was going to be
when I ran through it this
morning for the four time.
But I think I'm going
to wind down there
and just say that for all
the women in the room,
I really want to encourage you
to think through like, what's
the next step to taking your
voice to the next level?
And where can you step more
fully into your own leadership?
Take up new skills and
new armor and new weapons
to change the world
and make it better,
and to recognize as well that
your heroine's journey is
your own story.
And you get to choose
how you live it.
And that inevitably there
is a heroine and a warrior
woman in all of us, I think.
That's what I believe.
And how we get there
is within our own path,
and our own story,
and our own divining.
But that it's really
critical that we
are action-oriented in it.
That we claim it
ourselves rather than
allowing ourselves
to just be pushed
through the flow of
our lives, we really
need to swim with the current.
If that makes sense.
And step fully into
the opportunities
that are there for us
to battle for the world
that we want to live in.
So I think that's it for today.
Very heady and esoteric, but
I hope you guys enjoyed it.
I'm more than happy to take some
questions if you would like.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Thanks for coming in.
I have many, many questions,
but I'll limit it to one.
ELIZABETH CRONISE
MCLAUGHLIN: That's fine.
You can ask many,
many questions.
I'm good with that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, maybe
we could talk after--
ELIZABETH CRONISE
MCLAUGHLIN: OK.
Sure
AUDIENCE: But my
question is around
I try my best to subscribe
to feminism blogs,
and listen to different
speakers, and promote.
But then I feel that
when I am sometimes
asked to summarize
what I've heard,
I have a very difficult
time summarizing it.
Because I don't
live the experiences
that many women experience.
ELIZABETH CRONISE
MCLAUGHLIN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And do you have tips?
If you can help with--
ELIZABETH CRONISE
MCLAUGHLIN: Yeah.
Well so let me ask
you a question.
When are you asked
to summarize it?
AUDIENCE: Generally
with other men.
ELIZABETH CRONISE
MCLAUGHLIN: Yeah.
OK.
Got it.
So that's a really
interesting point
because let me just say this.
I am a very big believer that we
are not just at a turning point
for women, we're at a
turning point for men.
And I talk quite a bit about
the idea of sacred masculinity
and modeling good
masculinity to other men.
So first of all,
kudos to you for being
willing to be a change
agent on that front,
because there are a lot of men
who aren't willing to even make
the effort.
But the second thing
I would say about this
is that there is in some
sense no substitute for men
talking to women
about their own--
about the experiences of women.
Meaning that you can
summarize to a certain extent,
and of course you can do it
to the best of your ability.
And the next thing that
comes out of your mouth,
if it were me, would
be, by the way, are you
talking to your wife about this?
Are you talking to
your sister about this?
Are you talking to your
daughter about her experiences?
So that you're learning it--
and learning it through the
prism of multiple women's
experiences, if
that makes sense.
And I will also
just add that there
is nothing wrong with asking,
what can I do to do it better?
You know, what can I do
to make it better for you?
What can I do to make it
better for women generally?
How can I be a better advocate?
So I think it's not
just about how can I
summarize what I'm
reading about, but also
how can I propel men
to be more engaged
in the conversation about what
healthier masculinity would
look like, and how to make the
world a better place for women
generally.
Does that make sense?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Thank you so
much for coming here.
Thank you so much for your talk.
It was actually pretty
nice and very enlightening.
You mentioned a couple of times
this idea of a masculine model
of leadership.
And I was wondering
what, in your view,
a feminine model of leadership
or a gender neutral model
of leadership would look like?
ELIZABETH CRONISE MCLAUGHLIN:
So this is a really-- this
is actually what
we normally do when
I go in and do corporate
training and consulting.
So you've given me a nice
little transition here.
So we have something we call the
aligned leadership model, which
is a model that actually
has what we would consider
to be like more feminine
qualities of leadership
attached to it.
It is fundamentally an
emotionally intelligent model
of leadership.
And it starts from the place
of thinking through leadership
from--
I mean, there's 12
points on a pivot wheel.
It would take me a whole
other hour to go through it.
But fundamentally it
starts from a place
of the most effective leadership
in today's environment
being leadership that starts
with curiosity and compassion.
And so it's not,
I am the King, I'm
the ultimate know it all of
how this company should run.
But really, more of a
questioning, a consistent
questioning of how
can we improve?
What am I good at?
What is my team good at?
How can I look at what my
gifts are and where I'm weak,
and build an organization
that fills in the gaps?
How can I value everyone's
gifts on my team, right?
And it also talks
through the concept
that I shared with you
today of growth as one
of the main metrics of success.
So to me, I wouldn't
want to call it
a feminine model of leadership.
I think it's-- I think
it's far more healthy.
Right?
Our aligned leadership
model that we teach
is really about, how do you
create healthy ecosystems
inside companies where
everyone is functional
and, moreover, that is
holistic, so that it's not just
about what the person
can perform at work.
I mean, you guys are
amazing in here, by the way.
I have to say that of all
the working environments
that I've stepped
into, this one seems
to care the most about the
totality of the human beings
who work here.
And that is amazing to
me, and truly something
to be honored and
admired and uplifted.
But so many environments that I
walk into only care about what
happens to the individual
in terms of how they
can provide for the company.
Right?
And how they can perform
when they're there.
And if somebody's
spouse is dying,
or someone's child is
having a crisis, who
cares as long as the
bottom line needs are met?
Aligned leadership,
to me, is really
about recognizing that
we're all connected.
That organizations are only
as healthy as the individuals
who are within them.
And that just in the
same way that each of us
have gifts to
contribute to the world,
organizations do as well.
And so mission is really
critical and important,
and making decisions
based on mission
that are aligned with
also all the individuals
that make up that mission
creates environments
that people want to live in,
and work in, and are loyal to,
and that you can't
imagine leaving.
And just having
talked to some of you
today as I was walking
around before here, I mean,
that's very present here.
Right?
That degree of respect
and understanding
of the way in which everybody
who works here is connected
and the needs of
everyone being met.
So that to me is
about as close as I
can get without doing
like a full blown all day
long training like I normally
do in corporate environments
like this.
But yeah, it really is
about emotional intelligence
fundamentally as a principle.
And then mission and
purpose and making
all of your decisions about
your people and the people
who work for you as
if we're a family.
Because we are.
Right?
Make sense?
AUDIENCE: I had a
question about something
you mentioned earlier.
Earlier you said that
the stories of many women
had been erased.
Is there some place
we could go to look at
and we could find those stories
that have been repressed?
MCLAUGHLIN: Well so if
they've been erased,
you have to do a lot of digging.
So I would tell a story
about this that's kind of--
that really brought
this home to me.
But I will tell
you that it took me
about three hours of like
serious, serious digging
on the internet to find anything
that remotely looked like.
So my maiden name is
Cronise, as you all know.
And my father is
really into ancestry.
So one of the things
that we discovered
when he did all of this
work is that our family
on my father's
side is originally
from Alsace-Lorraine.
And the spelling of our
name originally in German
means iron crown.
And so I went digging
because my father was--
we were ironworkers apparently
and the 15th century.
You know, my dad's gone all
the way back through all this.
But I went digging to see,
well, what's the reference
point for this name?
I discovered in like
three hours of kind
of falling down a rabbit hole--
this is the old lawyer
in me, the researcher--
that there was this thing
called the iron crown.
Some of you may
know historically.
But the iron crown
was originally
commissioned by a queen in the
third century whose name I'm
now going to forget
because nobody's ever
heard of her because the history
has been completely erased.
But I did a whole podcast.
I run this podcast called The
Women's Leadership Podcast.
I did a podcast on
just this experience
of recognizing that there had
been a woman who basically had
been the head of something
the size of the Ottoman Empire
at some point in our history
that none of us know about.
Like I literally had
not heard of this woman
ever before until I went
digging for all of this,
because the stories that
we are taught about history
are the stories of men.
And so to some extent it's about
your degree of-- we're back
to curiosity again--
your degree of curiosity
about women's history.
And to some extent, it's
also about recognizing
that many of our traditions have
always been oral traditions.
And so this is one
of the reasons why
women's storytelling
still is really important,
and one of the reasons
why I encourage women
who want to know about even the
history of their own families
to go into their grandmothers
on tape before they die.
Because otherwise it
gets lost if it's not
written down somewhere.
So I wish I could
say that there was
like a magic
un-eraser button that
would bring all of this
back, but I think some of it
has to be about how far
are you as an individual
willing to do the dig, to then
share it with the collective.
I mean, this is a great
opportunity, by the way,
for a project.
Like somebody should start
a reclaiming women's history
project, if it's
not done already,
just so that we can start to
see like all the gaps there.
Yeah.
So that's my answer to that.
Individual choice, I
think, at this point.
AUDIENCE: So I am lucky to
be in a leadership position,
and I have a team that
has one other woman on it
and the rest are men.
And the team that I
lead are generally
somewhere in the range of about
15 years behind me career-wise.
And what I've tried to
do is to adapt my style
to the needs of each
person on the team,
because they are very different.
Their experiences are different,
their communication styles
are different.
And try to give that
hand up to all of them.
And what I have found
in the last year or two
is that I sometimes
have people call me
out as favoring the
woman on the team
even though when I sit down
and talk to them about all
of the ways that I'm investing
in their careers and the things
that I'm doing for them,
they recognize that they're
getting as much or more.
And so you know,
as you were talking
about our responsibility of
kind of bringing up other women,
you know, what about the people
who stand on the sidelines
and go, well see, you're
just playing favorites
and that's just no better?
ELIZABETH CRONISE
MCLAUGHLIN: Right.
Right.
So it's hard to
give up privilege.
You know, as I said, it's really
hard to give up privilege.
And some of what the
communication that we all need
to learn, I think, to do
better is also to say equity
is not about playing favorites.
Right?
Meaning that, and
the image that I
share with people about
equity versus equality
is that in order to reach
true equity culturally,
you do have to lift up people
who historically have not
had the extra lift.
Right?
It's like, think about
it from this perspective.
The image that I've seen on
this that's so descriptive
is you've got people at
three different heights
behind the fence.
Right?
And equality is that
everybody gets to stand
at the same place on the fence.
Equity is that everybody
can see over it.
Right?
And so sometimes that means that
from a historic perspective,
you have to do
things differently
in order to create equity.
There will be a
point, hopefully,
in the future where we
don't have to do that.
But to me, first of all,
that's not playing favorites
so I wouldn't call it that.
I guess that's the thing.
You can shout it out
and say, actually
that's not what I'm doing.
And do what you're
already doing there,
which I think it sound
like, I hope it's
working to a certain extent.
But the flip side
of that as well
is that if we do
not actually start
to make different choices
in corporate environments
as leaders, nothing shifts.
Right?
Like my biggest client is a
publicly traded investment
bank.
And they discovered-- they
did some research last year
and they discovered that only
4.7% of their senior executives
are women, even though
they hire 35% as women.
And they're losing people
and they've never kind of
investigated why.
Which is crazy to me, but
they're never looked at it.
One of the things that
I've had to say to them
is, why are you not recruiting
at historically women's
colleges?
Right?
Why are you not thinking
about maybe the fact
that you need to provide
different kinds of leadership
training for women so that
they understand how to navigate
this environment better?
Why are your senior male
leaders not signing on
to initiatives that say,
we're making a commitment
as an organization
to gender parity,
and here's what we're
willing to do about it.
Here's the investment that
we're willing to make,
here's the training programs
that we want to ascribe to.
Because the other thing
is that the unfortunate
thing about being a woman leader
right now in some environments
is that you have to do the
emotional labor of educating
people about what it is
that needs to change.
And it is so much easier
if senior male leaders also
sign onto that as allies
so that the messaging comes
from other men.
Right?
We're back to this issue of
how can you kind of like--
how can other men work as
allies to educate other men
about the benefits
of what's happening?
So I don't know.
I don't want to tell you
what all the solutions should
be for you, but it
does sound to me
like you need some male allies
as well on this front who
can communicate this to your
team in ways that make sense,
so that you're not the
one that is bearing
the burden of doing
the right thing
and having them feel
like that's unfair.
Helpful?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And it was more--
I mean, I feel like on our team,
we have very good communication
and we talked through this and
everybody's on the same page.
But as I look around and
you use that analogy of kind
of giving a hand
up to other women,
it is something that everybody
kind of has to think through
in terms of, is this
going to be misperceived
as preferential treatment?
Or what's the best
way to communicate
that it isn't really?
And I think you did a
good job of covering that.
Thank you.
ELIZABETH CRONISE
MCLAUGHLIN: Yeah.
You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I wanted to get your
thoughts on this situation.
It's not happening in this
company, another company,
to a friend of mine.
She wanted to switch teams
within the same company, had
an offer with another team.
She was pregnant.
A few weeks before
her delivery, she
talks to the manager,
a new manager,
is offered this position.
She plays the devil's
advocate, saying
hey I'm going to be
gone a few months.
I totally understand
that, was the response.
We still want you here,
we value you here.
Baby is born, it's
been two months now.
Now she gets a call
saying, we think
this position is no
longer a great fit,
we are not sure we
would value you as much.
It's a pretty reputed company,
I can't tell you which it is.
A very close friend of mine.
I'm angry.
And the manager
talks to her saying,
I want to grow the people
who are currently in the team
to be the manager.
Well nothing's changed, her
pregnancy hasn't changed,
the same people continue
to be in the team.
Now there's suddenly a question.
Now the way she's
responding is she's
being the mentoring role
for this manager and saying,
hey, do what's
right for the team.
So business-wise, the
right thing for the team
is not to wait for a
couple of more months
for her to get done back?
And which is what is
likely the manager
is hoping to hear from her.
And I don't want her
to be in a position
where she's no longer
going to be as much valued.
The other options
are, we create one--
we'll create a new
opportunity that's
like one third of what
you were supposed to own.
It doesn't make sense from
owning the whole thing,
why would I go back
to owning a third?
This is a big corporation here.
I don't want her to fight
against this corporation.
Her career would be
ruined after this.
And so she--
I mean, if you just wear the
business hat, it feels like,
yeah the manager made a
stupid mistake probably
to offer her a job
and she's going
to disappear in a few months.
But I was happy that he
did thinking the long term
potential and the
long term value.
What do you typically recommend?
I'm sure this is just
one of many instances
that are happening
out there today.
ELIZABETH CRONISE
MCLAUGHLIN: It's true.
You know, I have
to say that it's
really unfortunate because I
hear stories like this a lot.
Pregnancy discrimination
is still very real.
To the point where when I'm
coaching women leaders one
on one, we have conversations
proactively when
they want to even get pregnant
about how they have to prepare
their team for
that, how they have
to prepare their senior
leadership for it,
how to disclose it.
Women I coached through
job transitions,
like, when do I tell people
I'm pregnant while I'm
interviewing?
These are all incredibly
difficult questions
that we still have
to think about.
Which is crazy to me.
But all that said, for
your friend's situation,
you know, I guess
the lawyer in me
initially says she couldn't
find a good employment lawyer
and actually ask some questions
about what the strategy there
has to be from a
legal standpoint.
And I know you don't
want her to sue,
but I will tell you
that the employment
lawyers that my company refers
our clients to help people
negotiate situations
like this so
that they walk the edge of it.
Meaning that, that manager
knows that he's doing something
that's not quite right.
You know, I mean
it's obvious, or he
wouldn't be having
the conversation
the way that he's having it.
If she is able to come back
with something that says,
you made me this offer
when I was pregnant,
you knew that I was pregnant.
I understand you now
want to grow the team,
but this is the offer
that was made to me
and I still add value here.
With the right kind of language
that like basically signals
that she knows what
her rights are,
that may actually help the
situation dramatically.
And I can give you the number.
I have a very dear friend
who is like the past head
of the employment bar in
DC and knows everybody
in the country who
does this kind of work,
and could find her
someone to talk to.
But that would be
an initial strategy
that I would want
to approach it from.
And then from the place of
thinking through the business
end of it, you know, the
idea of what value you add.
Her value has not changed.
And so to me, I don't see
that there's any business--
I don't think he made a mistake.
I think what's happening
now is that he's second
guessing for all the traditional
stereotypical reasons.
Is she going to be available?
She's going to have
a baby at home.
Is she going to be as dedicated
to the job as she was before?
You know, all these
sorts of issues.
And some of that has to be about
her taking the lead to say,
I'm here, I'm available,
I'm ready, I want this,
I'm going to do it.
Nothing's going to fall through
the cracks, I'm committed.
It sucks that women have to
have these conversations still
forward looking, but they do.
And so I think it's got to
be the combination of her
an self-advocacy, to bring us
back to where we've been today.
And also she definitely needs
a lawyer to just talk to.
And I'm more than happy to give
me that number after the fact
if you would like.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ELIZABETH CRONISE
MCLAUGHLIN: Yeah.
SPEAKER: So that's all the
time we have for questions.
Thank you very much,
everybody, for coming.
And thank you very
much, Elizabeth,
for coming to talk to us.
ELIZABETH CRONISE MCLAUGHLIN:
Thank you all very much.
[APPLAUSE]